las funciones diferenciables x que están
relacionadas por la siguiente ecuación
seno de x + coseno de james es igual a
la raíz de 2 además la deriva tate x con
respecto a tema es igual a 5 y nos dicen
encuentran la derivada de que con
respecto a tema cuanto que es igual a
cuartos y 0 es menor que x menor que pi
medios muy bien dado que nos dicen
explícitamente cuánto es la derivada de
x con respecto a t y queremos encontrar
cuánto es la derivada de 10 con respecto
a tema es buena suposición que tanto x
como james son funciones de t así que
podemos reescribir esta ecuación que
tenemos acá arriba de la siguiente forma
podemos decir que el seno el seno de
esta función x pero que es a su vez una
función de t
ok más
el coseno de esta función
james que a su vez es una función de t
ok esto va a ser igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 2 y tal vez te parezca un
poco confuso ya que no estamos
acostumbrados a ver a x como una función
de una tercera variable y estamos
acostumbrados a que ya sea una función
de x pero recuerda x que son solo
variables x podría ser
efe tt y que puede hacer je t'aime en
lugar de que este tema y deje de tema y
tal vez eso te parezca un poco más
normal y ahora si lo que necesitamos
hacer es encontrar la derivada de que
con respecto a tema entonces necesitamos
encontrar la derivada con respecto a
tema de ambos lados de esta ecuación así
que manos a la obra del lado izquierdo
me voy a tomar la derivada con respecto
este parámetro tema ok de esto
perfecto
y también lo voy a hacer para el segundo
sumando la derivada
con respecto a ti ok
de esto que tengo aquí
y del lado derecho también voy a hacer
lo mismo si estoy haciendo algo de un
lado voy a hacer lo mismo del otro lado
la derivada con respecto a t ok de esta
constante de la raíz de 2 perfecto por
lo tanto pensemos en estas derivadas
primero quiero tomar la derivada con
respecto a tema de el seno de x dt que
voy a poner con este color ok si quiero
encontrar la derivada con respecto a
tema del seno de álbum que es una
función de temp entonces tengo que
aplicar la regla de la cadena y por lo
tanto primero tengo que encontrar la
derivada con respecto a x con respecto a
x de la función seno de x de la función
a seno de x podría poner x dt pero por
simplicidad pondré simplemente el seno
de e
ok ya esto hay que multiplicarlo por la
derivada de lo de adentro con respecto a
tema porque x es una función de t
entonces a esto habrá que multiplicarlo
por la derivada de x con respecto a t
ok tal vez esto parezca un poco
contraintuitivo porque sólo hemos
aplicado la regla de la cadena usando xy
10 pero lo único que estoy haciendo es
tomar la derivada con respecto a x de la
función exterior en este caso la función
exterior es el seno de x ya esto
multiplicarlo por la derivada de la
función interior que es x dt con
respecto al parámetro t y podemos hacer
lo mismo para el segundo término y decir
a esto le tengo que sumar esta derivada
que voy a poner de color rosa entonces
ahora me voy a aplicar en la derivada de
esto que tengo aquí y quieres esta
derivada observa vamos a aplicar lo
mismo la regla de la cadena bueno me va
a quedar la derivada con respecto a
james de la función exterior la derivada
con respecto a ok de la función exterior
que en este caso es la función coseno de
g
keiko seno de que ya esto hay que
multiplicarlo por la derivada de la
función interior con respecto a t es
decir la derivada de y con respecto a
este parámetro te ok y esto va a ser
igual y después me queda la derivada con
respecto a tema de una constante de la
raíz de dos bueno esto no cambia con
respecto al tema por lo tanto su
derivada a su tasa de cambio va a ser
simplemente cero muy bien ahora pensemos
en estas derivadas primero tengo la
derivada con respecto a x del seno de x
bueno eso es el coseno de x el coseno de
x y no olvidemos a esto multiplicarlo
por la derivada de x con respecto al
tema la derivada de x con respecto a t
ok estos dos están multiplicando y
después observa tengo la derivada del
coseno de james con respecto a gem bueno
esto es el menos se note 10 así que voy
a quitar este signo de más y voy a poner
aquí un signo de menos y voy a poner
aquí el seno de y el seno de esta
variable
james ok y no olvidemos este de james de
tema
de g dt ok y todo esto es igual a cero
esto es igual a cero ok espero que hasta
aquí vayamos bien ahora qué cosa de aquí
podemos sustituir con estos datos que
nos dan bueno pues nos dicen que la
derivada de x con respecto a tm es 5 es
este dato que nos dan por lo tanto aquí
tenemos el valor de 5
y bueno queremos encontrar cuántas la
derivada de que con respecto a tema pero
también nos dicen cuánto vale bien aquí
nos dicen que ayer vale y cuartos
entonces en lugar del seno de james voy
a poner el seno de pib cuartos ahora
parece que nos faltan dos incógnitas no
sabemos cuánto vale x y tampoco sabemos
cuántos las derivadas de ya con respecto
a tema así que cuánto vale x bueno
cuanto vale x cuando jeff es igual a pi
cuartos para encontrar ese valor lo que
podemos hacer es regresar a la ecuación
original que tenemos acá arriba y decir
cuando es igual a pi cuartos bueno
entonces me quedaría que el seno de x ok
el coche no deje pero lo que queremos
saber es cuánto vale x cuando lleva a
alep y cuartos entonces el coseno de pi
cuartos esto es igual a la raíz de 2 ok
ahora cuánto vale el coseno de pi
cuartos
bueno estamos en el primer cuadrante si
pensamos en el círculo unitario estamos
en 45 grados y esto es simplemente raíz
de 2 sobre 2 raíz de 2 sobre 2 ok
entonces me queda que el seno de x es
igual y si tengo raíz de dos días y sólo
quito raíz de 2 sobre 2 bueno me quedo
justo en la mitad por lo tanto raíz de 2
- raíz de 2 sobre 2 es raíz de 2
sobre 2
y ahora nos preguntamos para qué valor
de x el seno de x es raíz de 2 sobre 2
bueno pues recuerdan x está en el primer
cuadrante 0 es menor que x menor que pi
medios por lo tanto vivimos aquí para
qué ángulo que esté aquí su seno es raíz
de dos sobre dos pues es el valor de pi
cuartos esto nos dice que x tiene que
ser también y cuartos cuando james
spears cuartos así que déjame ponerlo x
es igual a pi cuartos cuando me lleva al
epp y cuartos y por lo tanto aquí puedo
poner pi cuartos también y cuartos y es
más déjenme copiar otra vez todo esto
para que queden limpio me quedaría 5 por
el coseno de pi cuartos déjame ponerlo
así
el seno de cuartos de ping
cuartos ok a esto le quito
la derivada de ella con respecto a t la
derivada de james con respecto a t
y lo multiplicó por el seno también de
pi cuartos de cuartos esto me tiene que
dar igual a cero ok ahora nosotros ya
sabemos que el coste no de pi cuartos
esto es raíz de 2 sobre 2 lo acabamos de
ver raíz de 2 sobre 2 y también sabemos
que el seno de pi cuartos es raíz de 2
sobre 2 lo acabamos de ver raíz de 2
sobre 2 entonces simplemente me quedan
la raíz de 2 sobre 2
a raíz de dos
sobre 2 ya esto le quitó de james
dt
que ésta a su vez multiplicado por la
raíz de 2 sobre 2 y esto tiene que ser
igual a 0
ok y si esto es igual a 0 como podemos
encontrar cuánto vale de jane de t pues
qué te parece si de ambos lados divido
entre raíz de dos sobre dos así que me
quedaría aquí en raíz de dos sobre dos
entre raíz de dos sobre dos bueno eso es
simplemente uno después tengo raíz de
dos sobre dos / raíz de dos sobre dos
bueno esto también es uno y por último
me quedaría cero entre raíz de dos sobre
dos lo cual es simplemente cero por lo
tanto todo esto se simplifica a 55 por 1
de 5 ok
menos
dt de james
dt esto es igual a cero o dicho de otra
manera si sumamos de siete de ambos
lados voy a obtener que dèiem de t
que es justo lo que buscábamos la
derivada de 10 con respecto a ti es
simplemente 5
de lujo entonces aquí lo tienes la
derivada de ye con respecto a temps es
igual a 5 cuando se cumplen todas estas
cosas cuando la derivada de x con
respecto a t es igual a 5 cuando lleva
al epp y cuartos y cuando 0 es menor que
x menor que pi medios hasta la próxima